you can now buy a house using your
bitcoin as collateral one of the biggest
problems in the entire financial system
for bitcoiners is if you want to go and
actually get a mortgage well what do
they ask they ask you to show your
assets when you show your assets you're
like bam i'm a oh gee look at my bitcoin
that should count towards my net worth
right wrong the banks and the mortgage
lenders will not allow you to use that
bitcoin they don't recognize it they say
we don't know what that is that doesn't
count show us your other assets and then
of course many people don't qualify for
a mortgage because the bitcoin doesn't
count so now u.s home buyers can buy a
house by using their bitcoin as
collateral and they qualify for a low
interest rate 30-year crypto mortgage
milo is the company that is doing this
and so who is milo they're a fintech
company building digital bank to provide
financial solutions for global and
crypto consumers there is no dollar down
payment required it's faster than a
conventional mortgage and of course
there's no fico score or tax returns
needed you can add or withdraw pledge
crypto to adjust the rate as you go as
well it's just look you got the assets
or you don't fico score moody score not
[ __ ] matters it's just do you got
the assets or do you not we got two
quotes from joseph the founder and ceo
of melo he said clients expect us to
come up with the innovative solutions to
extend credit to millions of great
consumers the existing ways for crypto
consumers to access home credit has left
them with unintended tax liabilities of
selling for a down payment or worse the
opportunity cost of seeing their crypto
increase in value there are countless
stories of people buying property with
bitcoin proceeds only to see it increase
in value and be worth millions more
facts it's all over the problem then he
said with our new crypto mortgage we can
expand our offerings to consumers that
were previously denied by other banking
firms just for having crypto we have an
opportunity to make sure that doesn't
happen anymore and their bitcoin wealth
can now help them buy a property i
generally love this idea i think this is
a no-brainer and the more that people
end up actually feeling like they can't
hold assets and have it count towards
things like a mortgage the more friction
there is when you remove that friction
and say no now your bitcoin actually can
help you qualify for a mortgage that
means that you're reducing friction and
ultimately increasing adoption agree or
disagree boys
yeah i agree i think it's great there's
a no-brainer i think yeah for sure i'm
i'm curious as to how fast other people
are going to do it also like i think a
lot of people wanted this for for a long
time but it's one thing to see a company
like this do it versus kind of everyone
adopt it and this become standard or
like an acceptable protocol for for
people to do when they buy a house uh
but yeah i think it's a no-brainer like
you shouldn't have to sell your bitcoin
to go purchase a house with the proceeds
and then watch bitcoin ratchet up
another 100 150 200 whatever it is so i
think this makes sense for for both the
uh consumer and the company issuing it
what do you think john i like it it
helps people hold on to their bitcoin
it's basically a secured loan at that
point right taking your mortgage out
against your bitcoin um you have to
think about how the volatility and i'm
sure uh milo has thought of this as well
but the volatility of bitcoin if it
draws down 20 to 30 percent how does
that adjust your loan rate um and then
also why can't i know that some
companies are working on this but why
can't people do this with equities with
other assets that they own in their
portfolio um that they don't want to
sell and either get capital gains tax or
they just want to have the opportunity
cost of holding that asset um and why
can't they go get a mortgage again so is
that um well i don't have a mortgage but
you can do it with other assets but my
my whole thing is right like it's just
another option i don't know if it's the
best option i'm assuming the rate i
don't i don't know exactly what the rate
is but i'm assuming uh it's not good if
you were to put 25 or 50 down in cash
right so you have to take into account
kind of where you come at it from a kind
of a rate standpoint and there's a bunch
of different other factors but
ultimately it's just another option i
think that's good for consumers to have
to have the ability to use bitcoin as
collateral and have no cash upfront i
think that's good yeah this is a
no-brainer now people can get mortgages
they can buy homes they can build their
bitcoin citadel and they can use their
bitcoin uh positions to actually finance
it like debt is not good or bad it's how
you use it and whether you're
responsible with it or not and if you're
actually intelligent about the use of
debt you can build wealth and you can
purchase homes etc but ultimately a lot
of people have been closed out from
using debt because they've chosen to put
their economic wealth into sound money
and now all of a sudden when you get
economic sound money it's what happens
right
this ends up being pretty uh pretty damn
good